[Music]
millennials first and foremost get an
extremely bad rap
right like us millennials you know
everyone's always complaining that
like we don't do anything we are a
business that's been built
exclusively on millennials so frankly i
think it's
um can i swear on this podcast yeah of
course you can come on
uh i think it's [ __ ] it was kind of
your fairly typical
environment back then i think what we
always did have and what attracted me to
the business was
it was just this relentless ambition
that
was running through the entire business
what was the best piece of advice you
got early on in your recruitment career
the best recruiters are relentlessly
consistent
in terms of what they do every single
day recruitment is a game where
it's about a consistent amount of effort
and work over a period of time
no one's ever had one good day and done
a deal
no one's ever had one good week and done
a deal or done multiple deals right it's
about
day after day week after week month
after month building that pipeline